chris and rosie i mean you are quite  unfiltered on your podcast about your  own  yes yes yes  well weirdly we don't actually talk  about us personally having sex because  we haven't twice  because of what people send us in it's  pure smut yeah really the stuff people  send and we are really boring one of our  first ones that we got sent that really  struck a chord with everyone was some  lady wrought in i see a lady  and  because we said he got any questions and  she wrote in and she said i need some  advice because i'm this is the reason  i'm giving my husband his first foursome  this wednesday  wow  our initial thought was wednesday  definitely sounds like a saturday  you can't ever force him on him  i suppose it's easier to park on a  wednesday  that is true  excuse yet they get child kid  maybe  if you're doing a foursome you probably  don't know what day it is  [Music]  you